he sold it
as the warrior president victor against
the virus
this was donald trump's triumphant
return in root health
even if his visible gasping was a
giveaway
it was all filmed for a cinematic new
campaign ad
even if no one can be sure how this
movie ends
these are pictures of deep cleaning
inside the press briefing room of a
white house
come hot spot in the seat of the u.s
presidency
covert infection has spread beyond the
president himself
don't let it dominate you he styled
himself
medical advisor on the evening of his
return the morning after
donald trump grew into the role posting
on social media
flu season is coming up many people
every year
sometimes over a hundred thousand and
despite the vaccine
die from flu are we going to close down
our country
no we have learned to live with it just
like we're learning to live with covet
in most populations far less lethal
but within ours the tweet from inside
the white house
was removed by facebook and labeled
misinformation by twitter
we know that this is not the flu coven
is much more
serious it's much more contagious it's
certainly much more
deadly this is why we have the worst
pandemic
we have faced in a century so to make
that comparison
is not accurate and it should not be
made especially in a time like this
the president's medical team has still
not revealed full medical details
but it did issue a tuesday morning
medical bulletin saying he had a restful
night
reports no symptoms and continues to do
extremely well when joe biden wants an
update on the virus
floating accepted health protection
measures has played into the politics
here
donald trump's opponents sent a big
moment to roll out
the big guns he still doesn't have a
plan for this virus
seven months later he still won't wear a
mask
consistently and encourage others to do
the same
even when those simple actions could
save
countless lives instead he continues to
gaslight the american people by acting
like this pandemic
is not a real threat as he continues his
course of experimental treatment
this convalescing president is posting
condition updates
and campaign slogans on social media he
tweeted
feeling great he also says he's looking
forward
to the next tv presidential debate a
week on thursday
tweeting it will be great
at the weekend black chairs were laid
out in front of the white house
to represent covert deaths in the united
states
beyond the cinema presentation it is the
reality show
under a president predictably
unpredictable
james matthews sky news washington